Hey youtubers it’s charlie, since everyone’s
been asking me to do a legend of korra q&a
I decided it’s finally time.
Since my last korra video the production team
has downsized a little as they’re working
on finishing up book 3 and 4 and the sound
designer Benjamin Wynn is going to be releasing
some non-korra original music this year.
He hasn’t announced when yet.
If you haven’t seen yet, I started doing
weekly anime club videos to fill the giant
hole that avatar content leaves when it’s
not on TV.
I’ll be posting a new video for that later
today.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
Just like last time I picked 20 of your questions,
so here we go Number 1 - injustice warrior
241 asks who do you think the new villain
is going to be and what type of bender?
will we see toph and her children?
So grey delyle implied in a radio interview
that she would be playing an evil female water
bender.
That doesn’t mean that she’s the main
villain, but it’s going to be a similar
situation to book 2 where there’s a super
evil person and then there’s just a medium
bad person.
The creators kind of implied that the big
problem that korra will have to solve this
season won’t have anything to do with her
bending abilities.
So I would guess the main villain is not that
evil waterbender.
As for toph, since we haven’t seen her grave
you could assume that’s she’s on walkabout
like Zuko or she’s living with her family
in the earth kingdom.
Because she’d be super old.
Book 3 will be all about the earth kingdom
and lin’s family.
So even if we don’t see toph, we’ll see
the rest of the beifongs.
Question 2 - Jellybeans7854 asks can korra
go into the spirit world and find her past
lives like aang did?
Right now I would say that’s the only way
she’s going to be able to communicate with
them.
The concept of people’s spirits going somewhere
besides the spirit world when they die hasn’t
been explored a lot.
So until confirmed otherwise let’s say that
they’re somewhere on the other side of the
portal.
Question 3 - Alan Michael asks do you think
we’ll see a new series after Korra book
4, with a new avatar?
Not on nickelodeon and not for 3-4 years minimum.
The creators said that they’re taking a
long break after book 4 is over.
So the avatar content you see after that will
be all in the comics.
That will keep going longer than the show,
just because it costs less to make and doesn’t
take as many people.
Honestly I think that unless Nickelodeon changes
it’s mind during 2015 whenever book 4 is
over, the creators will do a different non-korra
animated show.
They’re both still really young, so they’ll
definitely have a follow up project eventually.
Question 4 - Marwa elmasri asks when will
they release the book 2 soundtrack?
They haven’t announced it officially yet,
but sometime before the premiere of book 3,
and I expect that late this spring or early
summer.
So you’ll probably see that soundtrack in
a couple months if not sooner.
Also, they put the book 1 soundtrack on spotify,
so you don’t have to buy it if you don’t
have money.
They’ll do the same thing for the book 2
soundtrack.
So you’ll be able to listen for free.
Question 5 - jojo allen asks, can you explain
what happened to zuko’s mom?
She changed her identity, her face and her
memory and eventually started a new family.
Zuko found her, but he didn’t reveal himself
to her when he saw how happy she was with
her new life.
But he did find her, so he got some closure.
Question 6 - James Kung asks, who’s got
the balls to tap Toph beifong?
You’re asking about lin’s father.
That’s a pretty common question.
The most likely candidate is the The Duke.
My second guess would be a character that
wasn’t part of the original series and someone
we haven’t met yet.
There’s also a rumor that Lin was adopted,
but we won’t get an answer until book 3
premieres.
Question 7 - darkwintre asks, what would you
like to see in book 3?
Actually I’d like to see mako and bolin
get more involved in the central plot.
During book 2 they mostly got stuck in capital
city dealing with Varrick.
If you saw the hobbit then think about how
the dwarves work as a single unit when they’re
throwing people around or cleaning dishes.
I’d really like to see some good fire ferrets
action either in a fight or when they’re
just snooping for clues.
Question 8 - Tommy Shen asks, will they go
deeper into the concept of energy bending?
I know what you’re asking, will they give
us a very descriptive analysis of the mechanisms
behind energy bending.
And no, I don’t think so.
I don’t think there are enough experts in
energy bending for that to happen.
Only the lion turtles could really explain
it better and I don’t think we’ll see
another one until book 4.
Question 9 - Izzy Goggin asks, do you think
they’ll make an episode where Korra and
Asami have to help each other.
I think we’ll see some different character
match ups.
But I don’t think we’ll see a lot of scenes
with just asami and korra.
Secondary characters on korra don’t get
a lot of screen time, just because the episodes
are so short.
I would recommend you start writing some fan
fiction.
As long as it’s not too gross I’ll totally
give you a shout out.
Question 10 - Matthew Levis asks do you like
last airbender or Korra better?
We’ll there’s a lot more airbender content
than korra right now, so I’m really waiting
to see book 3 and 4 before I definitively
say which I like better.
My opinion tends to change year to year based
on new things I see.
So I try not to get hung up on old series
too much.
Question 11 - Timelord tennant asks, who would
win in a fight.
Toph Beifong or the weeping angels?
If the angels could make toph afraid enough
to hesitate, they could definitely get her.
Plus since angels can only move when you’re
not looking at them, toph would have to continuously
pound the ground with her feet to get visual
sensory information using the soundwaves.
If they fought and she wanted to win, she’d
have to be running in place the whole time.
Question 12 - adam tolentino asks what was
your least favorite thing about book 2?
The amount of time allotted for developing
secondary characters.
Because they only have half the episodes of
last airbender, secondary characters get almost
no time on screen.
So they just don’t feel as real as a lot
of the characters in last airbender.
Question 13 - kristine silmaro asks if the
creators ever did an animated movie which
characters would you want to see?
All of them of course.
Really though I’d like to see the story
move forward in time.
But I’d want to see all of the classic characters
in flashbacks.
a 90 minute movie has a lot more room for
extra characters.
If we do see a movie it would be whatever
that next thing they do after book 4.
Question 15 - lilly anne kitten asks, do you
think the earth queen will be beifong’s
sister?
I think the new opal character played by alyson
stoner is the earth queen, but I don’t think
she’s related to beifong.
I think beifong’s family is really tied
up in the politics of the earth kingdom though.
Question 16 - Sara Johansson asks what happened
to zuko?
It’s implied that he’s wandering around
the world.
I think we’ll see him again in book 4 briefly.
The biggest characters will always be korra,
mako and bolin, but that doesn’t mean that
Zuko couldn’t show up and help them out.
Question 17 - sweetkitty 013 asks variety
was saying that paramount dedicated a big
budget to planning a bunch of animated movies
in 2012 and last airbender was one of their
ideas?
What does this mean?
It means that the creators have met with paramount
about doing an animated movie.
They probably had to pitch an idea, meaning
they know what they want the movie to be.
But since there’s so much money involved
and those big deals fall through a lot I would
wait to hear something official from the creators.
Question 18 - Ivo Aboiltes asks do you think
bolin will ever learn metalbending?
Yes, they’re going to be in the earth kingdom
next season, so what better place to learn.
It would mean he’d need a lot of scenes
with beifong so I can’t wait to see super
serious lin and silly bolin try to communicate.
Question 19 - Randal Fisher asks, are they
going to deal with Korra being cut off from
her past lives?
Yes, that will be a big part of the plot before
korra learns about what’s going on in the
earth kingdom.
They wouldn’t travel there unless something
really important was happening.
Last question number 20 - Roberto Mileiro
asks, are we ever going to learn how aang
died?
It’s implied that he died of natural causes.
If it had been murder or a giant battle the
characters probably would have mentioned it
during book 1.
But everyone seems fairly peaceful about it,
I just think that means that he died of old
age.
Thanks so much for submitting your questions
again!
This was a lot of fun.
I’ll be posting my anime club video tonight
and my space dandy episode 2 video sunday
morning.
Be sure to subscribe to get them.
right now click here to get my book 3 predictions
and click here to get last week’s anime
club video.
See you guys tonight, high fives!